Do an interview with you,
Chuck Feeney with a billionaire who gave
away all of his,
uh,
molly and he,
he,
he did it,
he did it.
I'll give you an example.
I brought them onto the sales survival
school for,
for the artists language,
and I was trying to encourage him to
give some money to it.
And when we released,
he said to me this was,
this was this good where parents had a
financed by running ruffles and know
there that will sort of fundraising
projects and the kids were all in this
big,
this big hall and they were getting a
brilliant education.
So he's had the baby when we went
through the whole thing.
And I thought he was hiding impressed by
it.
He says,
I'm not going to give them any money.
And I said,
why not?
And they said,
well,
they're doing very well,
but perhaps if I give them money they
wouldn't do as well.
So I would take a leaf from his,
uh,
experience of philanthropy and put it
into sustainable projects.